turning to politics CBS News has learned
President Biden could announce his
re-election bid as early as next week we
do James is at the White House we do
good morning so what do we know good
morning to you Nate and good morning to
everybody well President Biden has long
said it is his intention to run and CBS
News has now learned that he could make
it official as early as this coming
Tuesday that's exactly four years since
the president jumped into the race in
2020 sources say the president plans to
make the announcement in the form of a
video release fueling the speculation
President Biden is also hosting major
campaign donors in Washington next week
in recent weeks he has made it clear
that he plans to run again and of course
this could set up a rematch between him
and former president Donald Trump who is
currently the front-runner for the GOP
nomination now one important caveat guys
we are told the president has not made
any official decisions or even signed
off on a specific date so it good slide
this will likely be an important topic
of conversation this weekend when
President Biden will be at Camp David
with staff and family Tony
indeed it will be Ouija thank you very
much